je sais pas ce que je fais du pas
correct j'ai perdu mon influence tête
qu'ils étendent accroché le manteau
d'encore ce que ça prend des enfants
avec une cabine ils ont fait du trou
dans le traîneau j'ai pris une balle
il ya un nombre croissant de jeunes qui
prennent de mauvaises décisions presse
l'armée des états unis aimeraient faire
appel à vos services
je comptais pas renouveler l'expérience
nous avons conclu une entente de deux
mois avec l'armée américaine le
capitaine jacobs va vous informer de
tous les changements qui s'opèrent
rendant lui c'est en plus de ces
quelques règles nous allons élever le
niveau de sécurité du site est-ce que
vous avez des questions oui c'est un
jour de joie nous fabriquerons haussier
pas des joueurs je veux tu le père noël
quel est le but de votre vie dit bien en
vacances chasse et bien tué quelque
chose aux travailleurs sacré appétit
c'est pour ça que les mythes avic
pluvieux questionnaire écrit lui aussi
près pareil non c'est le fait de donner
six cartes semaine
je suis venu d'arracher la tête gros pot
crafted premier je crois que j'ai eu
cette job parce que je suis grand et
joyeuse
mon passé ordures de quoi tu es capable
oui madame je te ferai des biscuits pour
la route
[Musique]
celui-ci génère il varie de mort est
clair et bien pire elle peut vous
arracher le paka de raincourt
[Musique]